a lot of controversy these days Candace
I guess but in the Twitterverse the
world yeah just everybody's excited
about being outraged yeah exactly that's
exactly right this controversy every
five seconds you know I had a guy on
before the guy that you just met dr.
Robert Schoch he's a geologist from
Boston University and he is a part of
this backdating of the ancient the
history of Egypt and they're talking
about you know all these different
structures there might be thousands and
thousands of years older than people
think they are and one of the things
that he's working on is that there was
coronal mass ejections from the Sun
somewhere around 10,000 years ago that
basically killed off a giant percentage
of the population on the planet
lightning storms millions of times
greater than anything we've ever
experienced before that literally which
like lightning coming down like rain
barbecuing the ground killing people
people forced in decay symbolization
resets it's almost like we need
something like that really be upset
about instead of being upset about
Roseanne or Samantha bee or Samantha bee
use the c-word today that naughty guys
it's just outraged culture yeah I say
everyone should just wait like 48 hours
if everybody hates you and then they'll
be on to the next person that they have
to eat yeah well that's one of the cool
things about the Internet is the the
psycho-boy it hits you hard but then it
goes back pretty quickly fast yeah it's
never that serious it's not like the old
days when someone got in trouble with
something boy that trouble stuck
I don't know that time I died I
genuinely don't know that time how old
are you 29 I just turned 29 yeah so
you're very very young in the
shit-stirring culture yeah this is all
new stuff to you it's new yeah and I
think the thing that sucks for me is
that I'm really conscious of it like I
wish I thought all of this was normal it
would be easier but like even when I do
things like just before this I was like
oh let me do an Instagram story that I'm
about to go on Joe Rogan I'm like hey
guys like we own Joe Rogan and I'm like
how weird I'm like holding my phone in
the middle yeah talking to this device
we sure we're of it that kind of sucks
that I'm aware of it like I it would be
so much more natural if I wasn't aware
of it you know girls that just hey guys
and they all day and it feels normal so
being conscious of it is kind of not
that fun that's probably the
best way to approach it done be
conscious of how goofy it is because if
you're just swept away in the zeitgeist
I don't know I think it's ignorance is
really bliss I think yeah I think there
are people that think it's the most
normal thing in the world
to just put your entire life on social
media and I actually don't think it's
the most normal thing in the world but
my entire life is on social media well
I've just met you but you seem like a
very bright woman and that's probably
part of the problem is you're not stupid
if you're stupid you'd be like putting
everything on Instagram and you'd be do
you do the selfie face this is my
favorite this thing I don't know I'm
really bad at selfies my cousin always
has to take them if we're in the same
picture but I'm getting good at my like
Instagram angle and like the things that
I say like I'll do you guys like this I
shadow like it's like it's it's that
ridiculous
my friend Cameron Hanes loves you he saw
you on Fox News he's like who's this
girl she's making so much sense he's
like super hardcore conservative yeah so
he likes when anyone is like young and
conservative like loves ben shapiro he
loves all that [ __ ] yes not excited
about you yeah people have been really
excited I think it's just because I I'm
I'm really unapologetically myself and
today that's like it's like seeing an
alien well it's hard to pull off right
because people get mad at you people are
trying to this this one thing that is
absolutely happening whether people like
it or not or believe it or not is that
people are trying to silence other
people's opinions if you say something
that doesn't jive with them instead of
saying wow this lady's kind of out there
are she saying some [ __ ] that I'm not
sure I agree with instead of that like
fire you know what boycott boycott
insane the outrage culture is insane
it's like do you really want someone to
lose their job we didn't like a tweet
like how weird are some of these
situations I'm like do you really this
person not to be able to feed their
family because you don't like a tweet
people are crazy yes they find targets
and they want to go after him there was
a bunch of people that were writing
boycott Joe Rogan because I was talking
about having Roseanne Barr on the show
tomorrow it's insane I know it's it's
like she doesn't have a right to speak
she can't even talk she can't even talk
even though I'm sure you don't agree I
don't agree with what she said right but
the idea that she can't
like have a conversation after that to
me is like the most bizarre thing in the
entire world but that is what outraged
culture is yeah it's like they need you
off the island
she doesn't even agree with what she
said right and she apologizes nobody
cares she's she's taken all kinds of
antidepressants she's drinking she's
[ __ ] out of her head like my mom took
ambien she just told me about this today
I forgot I forgot about the story
because I was telling her the story
about another friend of mine on the
podcast yesterday I talked about how a
friend of mine got on ambien made a full
meal cooked it ate it went to sleep got
up in the morning and had zero
recollection I was in total denial of it
it happens that's what my mom told me
that she went to bed got up in the
morning and she had gone up and put red
lipstick and a nail polish all over the
white bathroom carpet it was a little
she's painted on it like a child now AM
B she had zero recollection of it she
like this is scary shitless painted like
a little kid would like a two-year-old
would get ahold of your lipstick and
start drawing on the wall she did that
on this shag carpet and